[Música]
revista de prensa en directo América de
France 24 Marta Moya ya está con
nosotros en el estudio en el estudio
Marta vamos a empezar hoy en Irán porque
las portadas de la prensa local de ese
país destacan hoy el pronunciamiento del
día de ayer del día supremo Alicia sobre
las protestas que hemos vivido y pues
visto Mejor dicho estas últimas semanas
haciendo acusaciones a países rivales
Marta así Raúl buenos días empezamos con
el Iron Daily que titula el líder
supremo culpa a Estados Unidos e Israel
por planear la revueltas en Irán
recordemos que esta revueltas llevan ya
aproximadamente tres semanas empezaron
lideradas por las mujeres tras la muerte
bajo custodia policial de maxa Mini una
joven de 22 años que murió presuntamente
por llevar El hip hop mal puesto a manos
de la policía de la moral Y dice Bueno
que las palabras del líder supremo Ali
fueron la muerte de maxa Mini es
desgarradora pero este nivel de
destrucción alegando que Estados Unidos
a Israel estarían planeando todas estas
protestas de las últimas semanas vamos
ahora a ver qué dice el teren Times
titula líder supremo las violentas
revueltas fueron planeadas destaca una
cita del líder supremo en la que cita
textualmente declaro públicamente los
recientes disturbios y revueltas que
fueron una conspiración planeada por
Estados Unidos El usurpador y falso
régimensionista de Israel sus
mercenarios y algunos iraníes traidores
que viven en el extranjero dicen que
además el objetivo de estas protestas es
desestabilizar al gobierno iraní y no
habla de lo que le pasó a maxam mini tal
cual seguimos en Irán y destacamos ahora
a Marta el artículo de Miguel sáez que
recoge como ha cambiado el foco a estas
protestas en los últimos días Así es
habla de que el campo de batalla se ha
centrado en los últimos días en los
campos universitarios y bueno el curso
universitario empezó el 1 de octubre el
gobierno iraní los retrasó una semana
para intentar que los estudiantes no se
sumarán a esta ola de protestas pero
pues ha sido totalmente bueno no sea
materializado este deseo del gobierno
iraní y los estudiantes en estos
momentos también están liderando estas
protestas altamente reprimidas por
agentes de la fuerza del orden y fuerzas
paramilitares que están irrumpiendo en
estos Campos universitarios además
destaca que un grupo de derechos humanos
iraní con sede en Noruega cifra en 133
las personas muertas en estas protestas
y que bueno en la comunidad
Universitaria tiene planeado seguir
estas marchas en los próximos días
pasamos ahora a la prensa gráfica Marta
Porque las protestas en Irán también
están reflejadas en cientos de
caricaturas alrededor del mundo Así es
hablamos del movimiento cardon movement
que bueno hace bueno hemos destacado
cuatro caricaturas empezamos por una del
marroquí zanuni y Matt que dice bueno
pues como vemos aquí en pantalla es una
mujer sin el hip-jab que ha convertido
su cabello Pues en un martillo y está
atacando al líder supremo Ali y bueno de
fondo se ve aquí a la gente que sigue
protestando otra caricatura esta del
Jordán
que bueno pues como vemos aquí en
pantalla bueno es una botella con el
tapón simulando la cara de hammenade y
bueno dentro de esa botella están las
mujeres oprimidas con esos bueno con
pancartas pidiendo derechos con el
nombre de maxa a Mini y bueno el lema
mujeres no es el lema que hemos visto de
mujer vida y Libertad la tercera
caricatura que destacamos es del
hondureño Darío banegas es una silueta
desdibujada que bueno simboliza a Irán
como país y bueno dentro de esa silueta
está en la forma de la cara hay una
especie de cárcel que simula pues esta
prisión a la que están sometidas las
mujeres iraníes y saca de esa una
antorcha simbolizando las protestas las
la Revolución y en cuarto lugar
destacamos una una caricatura del
italiano Paolo lombardi que simboliza la
represión del líder
bueno que está apretando con su barba a
una de las mujeres con esos ojos y esa
boca no que están tapados también con
vendas increíble todo lo que relata la
prensa internacional en estas
caricaturas y cambiamos ese tema a Marta
Porque el medio estadounidense político
publica hoy martes un análisis en el que
critica desde legislativo de Estados
Unidos que se esté promoviendo la idea
de dominar a Rusia como un estado paria
Así es un artículo de opinión que titula
una idea peligrosa para castigar a Putin
dice que bueno pues esta idea de
Designar a Rusia como un estado
patrocinador Perdón del terrorismo es
contraproducente que es una herramienta
equivocada en un momento equivocado
porque Bueno pues no persigue el
objetivo de negociar que al final es
bueno el objetivo que tienen que
perseguir las partes en este conflicto
en Ucrania dice que Joe biden bueno se
ha resistido a esta medida pero que
desde el legislativo cámara de
representantes y senado esta idea está
sobre la mesa y que bueno Qué significa
esta idea Bueno pues que puede activar
controles a las exportaciones frenar las
asistencias al exterior y alivios a la
deuda y puede sancionar a personas que
bueno tengan negocios y relaciones con
el estado sancionado en este caso sería
Rusia pero que sobre todo pues genera un
estigma Bueno al nombrar a Rusia como un
estado paria además dice que es
contraproducente porque Estados Unidos
tiene que trabajar con Rusia en la
escena global aleja a la mesa de
negociación a las partes en turbia
inútilmente la palabra terrorismo
dificulta además la vida de millones de
civiles rusos y bueno supone una peligro
para una escalada por parte de Rusia
dice este análisis o este artículo de
opinión de político que a pesar de todo
Designar a Rusia como un estado paria no
aleja la posibilidad o es muy remota la
posibilidad de que Moscú cambie el rumbo
de la guerra y lo que tiene que hacer
Estados Unidos es seguir apoyando a
Ucrania Gracias Marta por toda la
información mañana con más de revista de
prensa mañana